in late 2016 something strange happened
when you opened up instagram at the
exact same second everyone's feed filled
up with this mysterious bright orange
square you couldn't scroll instagram
without seeing the orange squares from
everyone every big influencer was
posting it without explanation from
kendo jenner to haley bieber
the only clue users had to go off of was
the description that linked to the
account and hashtag fire festival
a month later this video was released
the actual
experience all expectations and there's
something that's hard to put into words
all these things that may seem big and
impossible
or not
it gives people that type of energy that
type of power this flashy promo video
promised paradise two transformative
weekends at the ultimate new luxury
music festival on an island in the
bahamas once owned by pablo escobar
where you would be flown in on a private
jet to a private island filled with the
biggest stars and models the biggest
artist and the finest food while you
dance the night away to music from blink
182 taiga and more and the best part
tickets were on sale right now for the
luxurious price of one thousand to
twelve thousand dollars per tickets or
up to two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars for the super luxurious group
vip packages
the world had never seen such a music
festival like this before if you don't
know practically every music festival
today are catered to the masses the
plebs think coachella or edc or ultra
tickets to these festivals only cost a
few hundred dollars so practically
everyone can afford to attend if you
want to ball out a tiny bit there are
vip options and tables for more but it
was for the masses the peasants there
was no exclusivity around it but this
new fire festival it was high and luxury
luxury accommodation and gourmet dining
was the standard only the world's most
famous and wolfy would be attending pair
that with the viral influencer marketing
and fire festival blew up
in no time 8 000 suckers had already
bought the one to twelve thousand dollar
tickets making the company 26 million
dollars it was unreal but little did
people know just how unreal this
festival was
the weight must have been unbearable
but by the time april 2017 came around
it was finally time to escape to
paradise attendees flew in but by the
time they stepped off the plane paradise
turned into hell on earth
so we're currently in the dark walking
to try to find our luggage because we
went to one place already our luggage is
not there none of us know what to do now
it's getting late someone took our
our room
um they told us that it was a
free-for-all so we have nowhere to stay
nowhere to stay some people are missing
bags
we're just trying to get our bags pitch
black out there's there's trucks
craziness going on everywhere nobody
knows what to do all the resorts nearby
are sold out it's it's it's an actual
disaster i've talked to like five
different people that work for fire
festival about trying to get a flight
out of this place
and
this is what they got disaster relief
tents in mattresses piled up in the dirt
well those are your mattresses there are
reports of feral dogs roaming the
grounds as for that gourmet food here it
is a cheese sandwich in a styrofoam box
now total chaos has erupted fans are
fleeing the fire festival on emergency
flights out of the bahamas
attendees were expecting a five-star
experience but arrived to a dystopian
wasteland with fema relief tents
mattresses piled high in the rain barely
any food and no way out
after all the hype the fire festival
turned out to be one of the biggest
frauds in the history of the music
industry and it was all centered around
one man billy mcfarlane
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime of my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
all you have to do is follow me on
instagram at jake tran and you're
automatically entered a few of you have
won already watch out for fake accounts
i will never message you asking for
money or to invest and this is the fire
festival scam
[Music]
part of the reason the fire festival
scam was so successful is that it sold
the idea of luxury if you come to fire
you'll be around the rich and famous too
unfortunately the reality is that you
can't get rich by buying festival
tickets but you can get rich through
investing
right now is one of the best times to
start investing in crypto it is a giant
dip after all not a financial advisor
but the problem is crypto comes with a
lot of taxes so if only you could trade
crypto without all the taxes well that
is where i trust capital comes in i
trust capital is the largest crypto ira
in the u.s where i trust capital you can
invest in crypto through your individual
retirement account allowing you to grow
your crypto tax-free itrust capital has
already handled over 5.5 billion dollars
in transactions with some of the lowest
service and trade fees on the markets
they have over 25 different cryptos you
can choose from and they're always
adding more you can trade 24 7 right on
their mobile app it's totally free to
open up on accounts and there are no
hidden fees monthly fees or setup fees
plus i trust capital is super secure
because they've partnered with industry
leading custody providers there has
literally never been a better time to
get started and as a special bonus for
my viewers if you open and find an
account right now you'll get a hundred
dollar funding bonus added to your
accounts all you have to do is head over
to i trust capital jake tran with the
link below and open a free account to
learn more that's i trust dot capital
slash jake tran for a hundred dollar
funding bonus with the link below
thanks to i trust capital for sponsoring
this video
what you have to understand about the
startup world is that usually the people
who are the best at bsing the ones that
are the best at painting the grand
vision of how their startup is going to
change the world the ones that are best
at bending the truth and fudging the
numbers to get that check to keep their
company alive are usually the ones that
come out on top 22 billion dollars in
three
hours
the problem comes when you bend the
truth a little too fair like elizabeth
holmes did with theranos and that's the
same problem our guy billy mcfarland had
with the fire festival before the fire
festival billy was hungry he wanted the
money the fame the status the notoriety
and he always found the luxury industry
sexy and appealing so he first tried his
hand at a company that turned people's
boring entry-level plastic credit cards
into these cool black metal cards just
like the ultra exclusive black american
express cards reserved only for the
highest spenders these new credit cards
would also promise cool trips and
concert tickets that some members say
weren't delivered
that venture crashed and burned so he
turned to his next idea selling people
tickets to shows he didn't have
billy went from pedaling knock off amex
black cards to going around promising
front row seats to beyonce and 200
tickets to the broadway show hamilton
all in the space of just a few months
but by the time the show came around he
was actually just using the money from
new buyers to purchase tickets for the
old buyers which kind of sounds like a
ponzi scheme
billy mcfarland learned two important
things from these two business ventures
first he learned that he wanted to sell
luxury second it's okay if you haven't
actually built the thing you're selling
because you could always fulfill on your
promise later
with that knowledge in hand billy was
ready to start the next chapter of his
life and it would turn into his magnum
opus his life's work
[Music]
so billy got to thinking festivals
you see after the first really big
really successful woodstock music
festival more than 50 years ago
entrepreneurs realized they were sitting
on a gold mine they realized that
people's lives had become so normal so
boring that almost anyone would jump at
the chance to buy a ticket to one of
these music festivals to escape their
boring everyday lives within just a few
decades what had started as a
celebration of peace love and music had
remained a celebration of peace love and
music while raking in billions of
dollars every year today festivals like
coachella have become kind of like a
yearly ritual for everyone from the
biggest celebrities to instagram
influencers and to music lovers alike
it's the yearly gathering that you had
to go to in that kind of social status
to be the guy that put together the
event that everyone goes to appealed to
billy he wanted to kind of be like
pasqual rotella the guy behind insomniac
the company that runs edm festivals like
edc but he wanted to be even more
exclusive more luxurious more high
status so he came up with the idea for
the fire festival the problem was it
didn't go much further than just an idea
for billy once he had the name the rest
was easy he partnered with a name that
almost everyone knew ja rule a famous
rapper from the early 2000s the rapper
was just famous enough that people would
believe firefest had to be legit i mean
what famous person would slap their name
on a fake festival the two of them fly
from new york to the bahamas to scout
for a location their plane runs out of
gas so they land on exumas a group of
violence in the bahamas and apparently
they immediately fell in love with the
place it seemed like the bahamas was the
perfect location it was close enough to
the united states that it was easy to
get to but far away enough that it was
still an adventure people already
associated it with resorts and luxury
and there were lots of hard-working
locals that can make the whole thing
come to life
so the two immediately launch a website
and start putting together the infamous
social media blitz attack that would be
the orange squares on instagram even as
it slowly dawned on them that the island
didn't have a really great
infrastructure that there wasn't a great
way to get guests there that there
wasn't any running water or sewage that
it was almost like we tried building a
city out of nothing but just like other
ambitious entrepreneurs billy believed
in moving fast and breaking things so he
had faith and pressed on
[Music]
as soon as billy pitched the idea for
fire festival pretty much everyone he
went to to make it happen told him it
would never work from vendors to
contractors to the locals who actually
lived on the island he had chosen billy
wanted to throw the festival on an
island without any infrastructure
anything even near his dreams of
five-star villas and massive stages
would take at least a year to build but
it was late 2016 and the festival was
only a few months away in late april
2017 and on top of that he didn't have
anywhere near enough money to pay for
all the stuff he was promising in fact
fire media made not even 60 000 in
revenue between may 2016 and april 2017
they made 57
443 dollars
by december 2016 the infamous orange
square instagram campaign had launched
and to supplement it models like bella
hadid and emily ratajowski were flown
down to give their stamp of approval for
the fire festival according to an
article in el magazine festival goers
could look forward to quote yoga on the
beach water trampolines sea bobbing
music art food and one million dollars
of real treasure and jewels hidden
around the island end quote from there
the hype and press just continued
by march 12th two months out from the
festival words leak out that the
headliners are going to include giants
like blink 182 migos and little yachty
everything on the outside was looking
great but not too long after talent
producer chloe gordon arrives to the
island six weeks before the festival was
set to take place and things were not
looking good
writing in new york magazine she said
quote flying in the water looked
beautiful but i was almost immediately
warned not to go near it because of a
rampant shark problem that was an omen i
regrettably missed end quote quote after
we landed we drove to the festival site
to assess our goods when we arrived my
initial reaction was huh
this was not a model filled private k
that was owned by pablo escobar this was
a development lot covered in gravel with
a few tractors scattered around there
was not enough space to build all the
tents and green rooms they would need
there was not a long beautiful beach
populated by swimming pigs there were
however a lot of sand flies that left me
looking like i had small pops still i
had hope end quote quote before we
arrived we were led to believe things
had been in motion for a while but
nothing had been done
festival vendors weren't in place no
stage had been rented transport had not
been arranged frankly we were standing
on an empty gravel pit and no one had
any idea how we were going to build a
festival village from scratch unquote
she soon found out that artists had not
been paid yet people started raising
doubts as to whether or not they could
pull it off but the rapper in
partnership with billy however jaw rule
wasn't having any of it quote to living
like movie stars partying like rock
stars and like porn stars end quote he
allegedly toasted after the fire team
decided to plow ahead again this is six
weeks away from the festival and nothing
was even close to being ready
april 2nd less than a few weeks away
from the festival the wall street
journal blows the first whistle with the
headline quote at up to 250 thousand
dollars a ticket island music festival
woo's wealthy to stay afloat end quote
the article warned that some artists had
not been paid yet and that fans who
bought vip tickets that included travel
and accommodations were getting nervous
because quote the festival's concierge
team has been slow to provide them with
logistical details end quote it also
turned out that around this time billy's
company actually defaulted on a nearly 3
million dollar loan while a potential
investment from comcast ventures worth
up to 20 million dollars fell through
but there was no turning back now so
billy just kept believing that right up
until the festival and that's when
everything went up in flames
april 27th a day before the festival
starts blink 182 announces on twitter
that they're pulling out of the fire
festival because we're not confident
that we would have what we need to give
you the quality of performances we
always give fans around the same time
attendees started flooding twitter and
reddit exposing just how bad the
situation on the ground was instead of
being flown to the island in a custom
private jet people were left stuck at
the airports for hours the people who
actually made it to the island weren't
greeted by smiling staff members in
welcome drinks they arrived to the site
of workers and 18 wheelers scrambling to
put things together instead of the
beautiful luxurious villas there were
half set up female relief tents and the
mattresses that people were supposed to
sleep on they were littered all over the
ground and soaked with rain there were
no five star chefs or gourmet food
there were cheese slices on white bread
the few fire festival staff that were
there were throwing people's luggage
from a shipping container
by now it was obvious that the fire
festival wasn't gonna happen and now the
only thing anyone wanted to do was get
off the island but even that was nearly
impossible
all over the island people were kept
waiting with no news on flights home or
how to get out it was a disaster
[Music]
after the fire festival went up in
flames the world was waiting to see how
billy would be held accountable after
all he was the mastermind of it all
in the end billy was convicted of fraud
he had conned investors and festival
goers out of 26 million dollars and even
though prosecutors recommended that he
spend at least a decade in jail he was
sentenced to just six years in prison in
october 2018. he was also ordered to pay
back to 26 million dollars but it's not
likely that'll happen anytime soon only
a few months ago billy was actually
released from jail to a halfway house
more than a year earlier than planned
today he insists that all his future
business endeavors will be dedicated to
paying back the people he defrauded
ja rule billy's partner in fire festival
was never charged with any crimes but
perhaps the most devastating impact that
the fire festival had was the market
made on the bahamas fire media had hired
hundreds of local workers to help with
the festival and when it all went belly
up they ran away and never paid any of
them
one local caterer named marianne roll
spent around 50 000 on equipment in
stock when she was hired to work at fire
festival but when everything went down
she was left with nothing it was only
thanks to a fundraising campaign that
she ended up recouping her losses many
of the other workers in the bahamas
weren't as lucky and they still haven't
received a dime
[Music]
you know who else had an island in the
caribbean every jepstein recently his
accomplice jaslane maxwell was just
sentenced to 20 years in prison for her
involvement in their operation
and yet no one seems to be in a rush to
go after effry and gazlane's customers
why is that how did their operation come
about how much leverage did they really
have over the rich and powerful that's
why we did a deep dive into the life of
the infamous efforty jepsteen and pieced
his life together in a feature-length
documentary but the thing is we can
still barely say his name without
getting demonetized let alone publicly
post an entire documentary on his life
which is why we released it as a
full-length private documentary that
goes into all the disturbing details of
every gepstein his early life his
sketchy path to wealth the sick stuff
that eventually made the world know his
name and much more
so far channel members have been loving
all these exclusive private
documentaries and all you have to do to
get access to our jepsteen documentary
right now and all the other full-length
documentaries that are too risky or too
twisted to post publicly is to click the
join button below after signing up
you'll have exclusive access to the free
gpstein documentary and others like the
bin laden papers the roots of middle
eastern terror mk ultra and much more to
come
this is all the stuff you should be
learning about in school and university
but definitely aren't and unlike
university you can get all of this for
just five dollars a month
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most youtube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
and we will personally refund you for
your first month after your first month
there is no refund pause the video right
now and click that join button below
[Music]
super interesting story that i wanted to
cover so if you enjoyed it let me know
what you thought in the comments below
remember you can follow me on instagram
for a chance to win a thousand dollars
i'm not sure how much longer we're gonna
run the competition so make sure you get
in there while you can oh yeah we're
also posting short versions of these
videos on our facebook page so if you
use facebook make sure you follow the
page with the link below but that's
gonna wrap it up stay dangerous out
there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you